[Música]
é a super herói
eu acho que a questão é que mesmo
gostando ou não a gente acaba não é
durante nossa vida assistindo e
voluntariamente depois de assistir a um
filme de super herói a gente sempre que
é ter esse modelo é a gente já se
imagina se teletransportar dando nem
documentos e coisas do gênero
a questão é que mesmo depois que a gente
cresce que a gente entende que a vida
não é um mundo dos super-heróis
a gente acaba dividindo o mundo muito em
heróis mocinhas e vilãs né
e qual seria a luta desses heróis a
gente a gente vê que os heróis eles são
dotados de superpoderes né seres
superiores quase divindades que
dificilmente erram e sempre no fim do
episódio eles conseguem alcançar é o
objetivo deles quer salvar os mocinhos e
os mocinhos de algo que não parece ter
saída de áudio em alguma situação que
parece que as pessoas só vão conseguir
ser salvas a partir da ajuda deles é bom
e quem aqui nunca leu em algum jornal ou
então assistiu em alguma reportagem é
sobre os heróis da vida real
né toda vez que alguém faz é algum
projeto ou tem alguma atitude louvável
admirável as pessoas logo falam que são
heróis da vida real um ato de heroísmo e
não me entendam mal eu acho que essas
atitudes delas tem sim que ser
veiculadas porque só assim que a gente
consegue inspirar pessoas que a gente
consegue é impactar as pessoas de uma
forma que ela também comecem a produzir
fazer algo positivo para a sociedade
a minha inquietação é no sentido de que
o trabalho social ele sempre é veiculado
um ato de heroísmo como aquelas pessoas
que fazem trabalho social são
considerados super hoje
e aí eu começo a minha reflexão falando
também um pouco da minha trajetória em
meados de 2013 né no momento que eu
estava saindo do colégio indo para a
faculdade é eu conheci o projeto
filantrópico flores de kahlo através de
amigos e eu me apaixonei pela idéia né a
ideia é justamente fazer ações
filantrópicas pelos quatro cantos de
belém nem atendendo crianças e idosos
moradores de enfim um público bem
diversa e eu falo sempre que um flores
ele foi essencial nessa minha transição
porque ele fez eu amadureci ele fez ao
adquirir uma consciência social né que
foi essencial nesse período de transição
da adolescência para a fase adulta
porque é nesse período que a gente tem
as maiores dúvidas e incertezas e medos
e eu me lembro muito bem é da primeira
seção que eu participei no flores foi em
dezembro de 2013 foi uma ação de natal
e eu lembro que eu cheguei em casa e eu
senti uma coisa muito diferente neste
super bem
eu senti que estava sendo útil para o
mundo de alguma forma mas vejam eu me
senti bem mas até hoje eu não sei como
as pessoas que eu tive contato naquela
manhã se sentiram porque eu não tive
tempo de sentar e conversar com elas de
conhecer a história delas é não tive
tempo de me conectar com elas de alguma
forma e depois dessa só vieram muitas
outras na eu fiquei aproximadamente dois
anos no flores
e é um projeto incrível inclusive ainda
está ativa elevando muito amor para quem
precisa em belém
só que eu comecei a sentir a necessidade
de me conectar mais com as pessoas né de
saber o que acontecia com as pessoas
depois da relação de entender a luta da
pessoa à vida da pessoa aprender com ela
né e criar laços mais duradouros
então foi aí que eu comecei a pesquisar
sobre empreendedorismo social e eu
comecei a pesquisar com ele funcionaria
dentro da faculdade né
como eu a aluna de direito conseguiria
aplicar tudo o que eu aprendi no curso
né
tudo que eu conseguia aprendendo com os
até então uma comunidade específica né
como é que eu conseguiria transportar o
conhecimento que estava entre quatro
paredes pra fora para esther na
comunidade
foi aí
foi aí que conheci o projeto e de gás
através do núcleo integrado
empreendedores juniores do cesupa e o
projeto legais ele nasceu justamente com
a função de prestar consultoria
assistência jurídica para comunidades
tradicionais
daqui do nosso estado hoje ele já é um
projeto que é interdisciplinar
não tens alunos de direito têm alunos de
publicidade tem longe engenharia de
produção de administração que fazem com
que a gente enxerga o problema e aí vem
o vários pontos de vista sobre o mesmo
problema né é justamente isso que a
riqueza de terem vários cursos dentro do
projeto e com ilhas é eu me apaixonei né
pela idéia de ilhas que era justamente
até lá o que eu fazia na faculdade e o
que eu gostava de fazer no meu tempo
livre que era trabalho social eu
consegui unir as duas coisas
e foi através da ilha que eu cheguei na
comunidade do espírito santo em tá né
eu falo que a comunidade é a minha
segunda casa e todos ali são a minha
segunda família
é a comunidade cristã de itália em santa
izabel né mais ou menos 20 minutinhos de
santa isabel e ele se auto declaram
quilombola mas eles ainda estão na luta
pra frente pra conseguir a certificação
e posteriormente titulação da terra
deles e quando cheguei na comunidade eu
lembro do primeiro dia que eu cheguei lá
né conhecia o contexto que ele estava
inserido conversei com a liderança gente
viu qual era o qual é o principal
problema deles e por que eles estavam
precisando do projeto e eu lembro que eu
fiquei assim a gente ainda bem que a
gente chegou até aqui porque eles
realmente estão precisando da nossa
ajuda
mal sabia que tempos depois na verdade
eu ia falar assim gente ainda bem que a
vida trouxe a gente até aqui que a gente
realmente precisava conhecer a eles
porque eu não consigo nem expressar
mudança pessoal e acadêmica que eu tive
na minha vida depois que eu cheguei até
a comunidade porque foi na convivência
freqüente de números finais de semana em
finais de semanas indo até a comunidade
que eu consegui perceber justamente o
que eu estou falando para vocês agora eu
consegui perceber que nós não éramos
heróis que eles não eram mocinhos e
mocinhas na verdade para além de ensiná
algo pra eles a gente aprendia
constantemente e aprende constantemente
com eles porque foi no contato direto
com uma etnia uma raça e com uma classe
diferente da minha que eu percebi que eu
só conseguiria ajudar eles a sanar os
problemas que ela estava vivendo lá eu
lutasse ao lado deles por uma igualdade
em uma sociedade tão desigual e eu
pensei de que forma eu vou conseguir
fazer isso como vou me sentir preparada
tratado lado deles nessa luta
e aí eu cheguei à conclusão que eu
precisava passar por duas etapas
a primeira etapa é reconhecer
privilégios né
é é muito difícil é uma tarefa muito
difícil a gente reconhecer o nosso
privilégio porque porque eu acho que uma
das coisas mais difícil nessa vida a
gente conseguisse ler de maneira
imparcial
é a gente colocar em outro plano e se lê
que ensinar o tc se diminuir a pena da
maneira que a gente é da maneira que a
gente vive é o meio que a gente vive
então é uma tarefa difícil reconhecer
privilégio mas é muito necessário
foi nesse exercício de reconhecer e
privilégios que eu reconheci o
privilégio de ser branca classe média
que teve acesso à saúde particular
educação particular moradia entre outros
privilégios aí que existem na lista e
reconhecendo meu privilégio conseguir
perceber que a gente está imerso em uma
sociedade que de maneira cíclica ou
psíquica perdura há desigualdade né onde
os privilegiados sempre são
caracterizados como heróis que vão
salvar os mocinhos e mocinhas que são
sempre pertencentes a uma minoria
e aí
passada a etapa do privilégio vem a
segunda etapa que é justamente a
desconstrução né
percebendo o nosso privilégio gente tem
que partir para o desafio de se
desconstruir diariamente que também não
é uma tarefa fácil né porque primeiro
que ninguém aqui não ser desconstruído é
todos nós temos uma sociedade patriarcal
machista sexista não racista homofóbica
entre outros preconceitos que
infelizmente se estendem na lista também
ea gente acaba tendo discurso enraizado
na gente desde que a gente nasce né
a gente nem percebe na verdade porque
vira uma coisa natural
às vezes a gente acha que até aí
inofensivo se reveste com brincadeira
mas a questão de construção é justamente
essa é a gente parar para analisar de
maneira crítica tudo que está enraizado
na gente desde que a gente nasceu tudo
que a gente reproduz por meio do nosso
discurso e tudo que a gente reproduz por
meio das nossas ações é essa é a
desconstrução diária e eu falo que é uma
tarefa difícil porque é muito complicado
você olhar para trás e ver quem você era
alguns anos atrás vias em nova eu falava
coisas que hoje eu abomino completamente
mas é isso é necessário e urgente a
gente fazer isso né porque só através de
desconstrução que a gente começa a
perceber problemas que sempre estiveram
do nosso lado problemas sociais que
sempre estiveram na base da nossa
sociedade mas que a gente notava e aí
que a gente começa a enxergar também a
luta das minorias né que são tão
invisibilizados e silenciados todos os
dias e não se enganem não achem que
ficar calado não enfrentar a questão é
uma forma de lutar com os problemas
sociais porque não é sabe ficar calada é
uma forma só de silenciar mais ainda
quem vem tentando recuperar a sua voz
então a partir do momento que eu passei
por essas duas etapas incompletas né
porque todo dia eu reconheça algum
privilégio diferente todo dia é uma
desconstrução diferente né
eu me perguntei então qual é o meu papel
qual é o papel de giovanna perante a
comunidade
qual o papel da comunidade que o
trabalho né
e eu entendi que meu papel perante a
comunidade quilombola e principalmente
perante as mulheres quilombolas é
justamente dar voz a elas e não falar
por eles né
aqui eu não consigo dizer pra vocês eu
nem posso dizer pra vocês o que é sofrer
opressão de gênero raça classe etnia
tudo junto
porque eu não vivo isso apesar de ser
mulher fazer parte da minoria que é ser
mulher
eu sou uma privilegiada dentro dessa
minoria eu sou uma mulher branca de
classe média que mora aqui na capital
mas o meu papel como estudante de
direito com o pesquisador o nome do
feminista é justamente dar voz a elas né
é pesquisar e entender o contexto das
pressões que elas sofrem e sempre
tentado a voz a elas
então só o fato de estar aqui neste
palco falando dela já é uma grande
conquista
eu já estou conseguindo trazê los aqui
pro meu lado mesmo que elas não estejam
aqui fisicamente e é justamente isso que
as melhorias precisam
elas precisam ser ouvidas elas precisam
chen enxergados
e pra você lembra que a gente falou dos
vilões que a gente divide eu falei nisso
pois é para muito longe de ser herói
quando a gente tenta desde tmar quando a
gente tenta silenciar a luta de alguém
a gente está sendo o vilão na verdade né
então pra mim a idéia de coexistir é
justamente se deixarem poderá em poder a
outras pessoas né
ninguém precisa ser herói a gente sempre
vai errar nós não somos divindade seres
superiores ea gente nem precisa ter o
poder só pra gente
a ideia de que existe é justamente
partilhar o poder é você olhar para a
pessoa que está do seu lado e fazê-la
enxergar um poder que sempre esteve
dentro dela mas que ou por fatores
externos ou por fatores internos ela
ainda não tenha conseguido internalizar
ela ainda não tenha conseguido perceber
o poder que ela tem de mudar a vida dela
e de mudar a história dela
então qual existe é isso que existe a
gente compartilhar o poder
é a gente empoderar as pessoas
diariamente porque só assim a gente vai
conseguir ser instrumento de mudança
social em busca de um mesmo objetivo que
é a igualdade
então a minha proposta aqui na verdade é
que vocês também façam esse exercício de
reconhecer os privilégios né devagar
claro por vez reconheça a 1 depois de
conhecer o outro e passado isso também
faça o desafio da desconstrução diária e
aí quem sabe a gente se encontra em
troca idéia de como isso muda a nossa
visão de mundo como isso muda nossa
visão a nossa percepção de nós mesmos ea
percepção da comunidade que a gente está
inserido
só assim a gente consegue de fato está
do lado de minorias e poder ajudá los
obrigada gente
[Aplausos]